this is a production of cornell
university
um okay thanks to you for introduction i
think although we still need to wear
tasks uh i feel it's so great to see
everybody here in person after i joined
in cornell for almost two years
uh time flies so i have prepared myself
to be in a kind of a slow pace to know
every of my colleagues here in a
relatively larger school but i never
thought i gonna have additional
challenges from a global pandemic
but on a very positive side uh the
pandemic really forces us to think about
the digital information technologies
especially not only for our daily life
but for almost every industry we are
working with
and especially agriculture so that
aligns well with my today's topic on the
use of artificial intelligence and
robotics for grief disease research and
management
and before we dive into this um specific
research project i just want to take
this great opportunity to also
introduce a little bit more about my
background my lab and my program so that
all of you can better understand me as
an engineer home as a hockey culture
which seems like
a weird position but i think that's
really the new trend for
interdisciplinary research in the future
so i was born and raised in acousto city
in china
famous for its beers and the seafood
as many kids grew up in an urban area
i barely thought about where i got this
food or what's the production system
behind the food i ate everything i
thought there must be a magic mechanism
i just go to the grocery store or the
market and buy them and that's it
then i selected my major in computer
science and uh continued my
undergraduate and master's studies in
china
um that's the place where i really got
the chance to take close look at the
production system in agriculture okay i
visited and lived with a brewer for
months so here is a picture to show in
the small pond he used to cultivate the
crabs and the fish for the agriculture
produce
and you see there is a smoke so every
day the guru needs to check the water
oxygen content
four to five times even during the
midnight so as a parent of a newborn i
really understand you know get up during
the midnight is really frustrating and
he needs to do that for months to ensure
the productivity of that season
and i developed a
algorithm that can do the prediction for
water oxygen content and then
automatically trigger the air pump
instead of heat and put himself into
that small island and turn it on and off
and that really helped him to you know
address some critical issues at least
allow him to have a full night sleep
which you know stop the burden a little
bit
so this deeply uh
kind of inspired me okay how i can
develop new technologies to solve some
real life challenges and make people's
life easier
and that
make me to determine okay i want to
pursue a phd degree in agricultural and
biological engineering which is a
natural combination of technology and
agriculture
so i ended up with the university of
georgia where my dissertation focused on
the high school food from phenotyping
and the closest harvest quality
assessment for blueberries and cotton
where i got to know both specialty crops
and field crops represented in georgia
and after i graduated in 2019 i ended up
with my current position as an assistant
research professor at cornell agritech
really have more opportunities to work
with you know different types of
specialty crops in the state of new york
i established my lab called the cyber
agricultural intelligence and robotics
laboratory just for care it reflects the
two things first the technologies we are
developing and second
the existing axiom for earth
about carrying the agriculture
environment and the human society
and i have a lot of members from a
pretty uh pretty diverse engineering
background ranging from mechanical
aerospace engineering
uh to physics and optics
and that's a in a pretty diverse range
even within the engineering also i hope
to to mentor or to advise students with
strong science background but who are
also interested in learning and applying
technologies for their research
and by nature my lab and my program are
really interdisciplinary
and my lab dedicated to the development
of systems engineering solutions to
complex and the challenging issues
facing by modern agriculture with an
emphasis on specialty crops
so when we talk about the systems
approach or systems
solution the first thing we need to
understand what's the key element right
in our system
so basically we have two identities here
one is a human ourself uh regardless we
play the law as a researcher or you know
gurus or you know stakeholders or even
just regular consumers right and the
other identity is the agriculture itself
and usually agriculture has its own
cycle right from the breeding to
pre-season like competition or sewing to
in-season monitoring and management like
want to right describe how the plants
really behave right during the season to
harvest and the postal heart so it's
really a food chain rather than an
individual sector
so now we have some things right uh as
simple as just a meter yard you can use
compare the plank height in the field as
a kind of phenotypic trees for whatever
research purpose or as you know advanced
as you know uh prior electron microscope
to help us understand the protein
structure
but we still lack a systematic way to
understand
everything is based on our interests
based on individual programs rather than
a systematic data-driven approach to
support all these efforts that's where
my lab proposed the concept called the
ym
it's a unified framework that consists
of three important elements first the
development of the new agriculture
sensors and the robots that can fulfill
the needs for modern agriculture
research
and production
second try to integrate all these
existing infrastructure and public
services for example the nasa satellite
imagery as a resource then we can
immediately enhance our sensing capacity
and capability to different you know
types of work
and the last we need to develop a new
data management and analytical tools
that can help us to acquire
uh curate analyze and realize all the
data we need by a different interfaces
back to different user groups as the
researchers will be more interested in
the trees as growers have been probably
more interested in the information that
help them to make decisions and as
stakeholders you know all about money
right so
by you know bringing this one ag
framework we just add the technology
layer between human and agriculture so
that we can really have a systematic way
to gather the data together to make the
loop close
so now no longer being just an
individual program or researcher
interested in for example in season weed
management
it will be starting from the breeding
program all the way down to the final
you know uh benefits for the post
service processing how a particular weed
management improvement can help the
system as a whole
so i just want to give several you know
demonstrate the uh projects i'm working
with the first one is for seed
technology plastic imaging i think for
any of these annual uh crops these are
the most crucial you know resource you
start your season from there and i
talked with my colleague alan tiller he
said hey you have a fantastic seed
coating technology that can wrap up some
fluorescent tweezers on the seed surface
and they use existing like a million
dollar imaging system to prove the
concept as you can see the juicer can
diffuse into the soil and then being
uptaken by the
plant and distributes to the shoot part
then being identified by this imaging
system but there are two barriers there
first
equipment itself is expensive like i
don't think anyone can afford a million
dollar equipment for their just a daily
research without sharing that
second it's a little logistic issue
right if we need to coordinate a large
scale experiment beautiful hybrid attack
and here in
ethica
how are you gonna manage that
so i said okay
maybe i can do something for this so i
developed a respirator pi based
fluorescent imaging system and the whole
system costs only a couple of thousand
dollars as compared with million dollars
but at the same time it will also
enhance the fluorescence signal you know
noise ratio as well as the spatial
resolution that we enable just using
variational computer vision method can
identify the uh plants you know through
the treated seeds versus the class from
like a controlled one
and that also gives us some new idea
okay so if we can identify the props so
easily
why not to use this to tackle some of
the weed management issues so that's the
you know case we bring in our wheat
scientists lynn askey here see let's do
some preliminary tests just a mixture
you know irregular we so you probably
barely see that but they're always
behind
or around the crop and we will be able
to identify that using very cheap
solutions so that's exactly how one ag
linked from you know all the way from
the seed technology to in-season food
management
and of course for those perennial props
we also have you know this preparation
things
okay this sounds good better
oh okay
okay yeah
so then for those perennial crops like
apples or briefs um it's better also we
need to prepare something beforehand and
we are working on a scri project led by
dr
robinson to find the optimal number of
fruits per tree
okay if we can control that well that
can maximize the profitability for
apocalypse
and we have the challenge is that how to
get accurate environment for the tree in
the trunk diameter and other you know
tree parameters so here i use a
high resolution laser scanner with the
full perspective capability so we just
digitize the entire archer from the
field to a computer so that's exactly
the 3d point cloud showing here you can
see all these details about the apple
tree and with that and now we'll already
be able to measure these two important
trunk diameters and the cross-section
surface area that can be used for
top-load estimation
and we are also working in progress to
identify all these reproductive organs
like your green tips maybe a police and
we can map that through all these three
over the growing season that can guide
us how to do the singing to help us
achieve the optimal number of trees and
even we can do something beyond that to
try to identify the branch pattern that
can help us to guide the pre-season
pruning or even things back with the
breeding program see if we can find any
genetic background that control tree
architecture would be suitable for the
machine harvesting
right that's actually you know the the
benefit of using one app and also i can
start from any of these in season one
for instance this is in collaboration
with very smart for tempo breeding uh we
developed a zone based data processing
pipeline that can monitor the
craft growth during the season try to
measure its morphological trees as well
as some of the biochemical trees so we
hope to use these trees to give
informative information for him to run
either the genetics analysis or the
breeding program that can you know
cultivate a new varieties that adopted
locally in the new york state
and the last part also about the
harvesting right when we talk about
harvesting the number one issue now is
labor
uh we just have a very you know weird
and worst trend
of the labor shortage
and all the gurus now reach to the
highest desire they want the robotic
harvester to replace human liver because
they cannot find the labor on the market
and for this delicate fruit like uh
cream berries blackberries or
raspberries the the challenge is that
they are not like an apple or peach
you can use a rich you know robotic arm
easily manipulate them you have to
design some soft robotic solution that
can gently touch that
and manipulate the fruit to keep the
post-harvest equality right basically
the shelf life
and it doesn't just because of the
creeper itself it's also related to the
perception system whether or not you
know the whole robot can accurately find
and localize all the fruit as well as to
determine whether or not the food is in
a maturity stage and ready to harvest
right once you determine that on the fly
during your harvesting you can also do
the online sorting so at the end of the
day the gurus will be able to better
price all the product based on their
quality and that sometimes can increase
up to 30
of their profits
in the same unit orchard orbit
that's exactly how the new technologies
really bring up everything together try
to make you know the whole system better
rather than only push a single position
so
in addition to you know that you know
advantage one act also foster new you
know interdisciplinary collaboration as
i mentioned we always start with a
problem in a very specific sector in the
agriculture system but then we found
that we can linkage back to you know all
these different disciplines even within
the agriculture cycle and also even
outside the agriculture itself right i
collaborated with many other engineers
try to propose new solutions for these
interesting problems
and in addition to that as i mentioned
one app is a new framework that can
better integrate different user groups
but before that as a technology
developer what i develop is what you use
you have no choice
the only choice is that you can buy or
not
that's the only feedback i got but here
with different you know interface all
these stakeholders and gurus can get
their necessary data and also provide
feedback
so that we also have the interaction
within the human you know identity that
can help us better design you know the
is technologies for everybody's needs
so-called you know human-centered design
okay so i talked about a lot regarding
different aspects uh you probably
remember the previous slides i list a
lot of collaborators under the plant
pathology part which is the main topic
today here about the greek disease
so this is exactly an example of a
radical collaboration between plant
scientists
specifically plant pathologies
in chronogeneticists and engineers
so we started this project with a small
conversation i were told that
disease itself
caused about 15 to 30 percent total
yield loss annually
and that reminds me
all recent
agricultural related studies have the
first statement is by 2050 we need to
feed about the 10 billion people around
the world and we need to double the
current here
okay so we need to double the current
yield but now we have a single aspect
that can cause up to 30 percent yield
loss
that's definitely not acceptable
and i was even more shocked by the
second statement
to such a high yield loss is under the
situation where we already use you know
over a billion tons of pesticide every
year in the us alone
it does cause other problems first
financial burden for bureaus they need
to purchase those chemicals
right second
climate issues although applying some of
the pesticides may not directly release
the greenhouse gases
but sometimes
you know producing those chemicals will
definitely release a lot of greenhouse
gas and that causes a significant
climate issue
and last all these chemicals have
residue right and sometimes this could
be harmful for ourselves
and also you know there is a trend that
people tend to use more and more of
these chemicals to deal with this
headache you know disease issue and that
stress our biodiversity and eventually
sometimes will lead to super pathogen or
maybe other like wheat species
that never a single you know chemical or
measurement we can deal with
that don't be you know
really disastrous for all of us
so specifically for grief we are
concerned about the two types of the
disease um dynamic audio
but yup
okay
no it's fine
uh okay so i hope this will sound better
and constantly
so specifically for these two types of
the disease the dynamic audio can
sometimes ruin the entire venue and you
have to replant everything and that's a
huge economic okay and the pottery
module itself almost infected all the
european you know cultivars and
sometimes most of them are widely used
for one making so itself is a billion
dollar issue you need to tackle
so to solve these we have two viable
solutions right first we can develop new
measurement practices
well control them in the field then
that's done second we can breathe new
cultivars that can naturally have some
resistance to this disease so we can
significantly reduce the
use of pesticides right while
maintaining a pretty you know healthy
lanyard or altar
during the season
but both of these will require the
evaluation of disease infection in the
field
so what do we do
we hire undergraduate students graduate
students postdoc technicians send them
to the field to do the scott
right it's very typical but sometimes it
can be laborious and subjective it
highly depends on your emotion it
depends on your experience even depends
on you know the time of the day how you
evaluate them so that motivates us hey
we need to develop something more
objective and more you know automated
that can solve this issue
and that eventually goes with the vision
based uh field approximate disease
scouting system
so this is the first generation of the
data acquisition system initiated before
i joined now
but i think they make a right choice to
use these customized
stereo camera
which is a research outcome from the
efficient lanyard project light by terry
base and agritech
and the good thing for this camera are
twofold first it can be easily mod on
any atv or utv vehicles that can be
easily found in any of the architectural
manual and second the strobe light you
know being used to minimize any of the
image changes or image variations due to
the ambient light
and here are some example images
the three images are acquired under um
in different venues on different time
over different years
although you still see some like
variation but not as much as you use
your cell phone take the images in the
morning versus at the known time
so this relatively consistent image
quality gives us you know
synergy that we probably can
do a better modeling to deal with the
detection of the dynamic interface
so that's where my lab developed
so we developed this overall data
processing pipeline to do three tasks
first we use the latest deep neural
networks to identify the infection areas
in each of these single images
and second we use a color modeling to
segment all these canopy from the images
and last we use the stereo setup to
retrieve the depth information which is
the distance
between your object and your account
so with the first two information you
already can calculate the severity right
by just taking the ratio
in each image
but in the field you have to
continuously collect the data and then
inevitably you have some overlap between
image frames and that's where we use the
depth information with the gps
information so we can project all these
2d image pixels
back to 3d world coordinates then we can
easily identify which part being the
overlap and we can remove them then we
don't need to worry about the double
detection problems here
and this is the video to show you know
how this pipeline works as i mentioned
we fit into the color images we
collected in the
field and the second volume outputs the
detection map of this infected region
and the third one showed you the canopy
area and the last one showing your
effective area which as i mentioned the
area without any overlap is neighboring
image free okay by combining all this
information together we will be able to
quantify the disease infection severity
for any of the unit you want coron
panel even pergola
and we did a statistical analysis to see
if we can find any correlation
between our image derived the trees
versus the human evaluation in the field
right and we found a pretty strong
correlation
which is permissible that means we could
potentially use this tool to replace the
human in the field for sculpting and the
one thing i want to highlight is the
scale if you look at the x-axis and the
y-axis yeah on two truly two you know
ranges
the image derived the same
only up to like 20 or so but for human
you can get up to something
and this is because of sub sampling
process by human evaluation
because for the image system we measure
every single leaf that is visible to the
camera so you take the full picture as
the you know camera can
however for a human it's hard for them
to um evaluate individual leaves right
um within
you know limited time span so they have
to do the sub sample
and it's kind of a human nature that you
tend to select the leaves represents
what's in your impression
if you you know barely see okay that's
heavy in fact you actually tend to
select the samples to reflect this is a
heavily infected panel
and that cause you select a lot of
leaves that have those you know highly
infected regions and costs up to 100
this is subjective but the system can
kind of minimize that not fully address
it
so we also use this development pipeline
for a fungicide trial experiment we want
to see whether or not we can use the
imaging to derive the trees to also
identify optimal management practices
right that's going to be very important
and we found it provide almost identical
sources of power and again the benefit
here for imaging derived trees is
the variation within each group is
smaller than the human evaluation
that means potentially could use the
image-derived trees to even identify
some subtle tree subtle difference
between the treatments that will help us
to address what would be the optimal
management practice for local regions
in addition to those accuracy effects
the more important thing is about the
spatial right when we deal with a very
large lanyard i want to know
where the spatial variation there so
because all the images are dual
referenced we can easily
you know back realize that any of the
gis system so here as i show because
this is a research file we don't really
see any significant spatial variation
but for some of the commercial ones we
would expect microclimate change gonna
cost a little bit different in terms of
the uh dynamic respiration or the
infection
and the in addition to this we also link
the back with the satellite imagery and
we got some like a fairly good
correlation that tells us you know we
could potentially use this to train
satellite imagery for better you know
coverage of all our
farms or vineyards
so although everything looks so far
pretty cool uh we still need to require
one operator
and the driver has to be very
concentrated about the driving itself
cannot do anything else
so that's the reason let's just make
everything autonomous to put together as
a robot so just in the past the season
we already deployed these robots in
different lane yards under different
groups of stage collect the images for
disease monitoring
and
this year only you already got 10
terabytes of data and that's you know
back again to the point where in the big
data area
also we are working in progress to
integrate the robotic arm for soil
sensing and sampling so as long as we
find the infected region we can also
stop the robot and start to drill the
soil and see if we can get other
additional information that can help us
to better interpret the disease
infection
so
to address all these affirmative
evaluations cool but for most of the
scientists as you all know you are
really interested in what's the actual
thing right behind the field of
observation and they want to understand
the mechanism or for example the genetic
background about how the plants respond
to different pathogens or different
diseases and that would require us to
use a microscope as a regular tool
so typically they will do that
by asking their pulse box for
technicians sitting in front of a
microscope
and turned the number of hypo being
developed by the quadrant module passage
and i did once and i never want to try
throughout my lifetime
it's just a
boring
period
but i really appreciate
all the past researchers can really do
that over time to make our scientific
discovery forward
uh so that's the motivation you know
nasa and the david initiated this pm box
so that they can address the data
acquisition issue now instead of asking
someone sitting in front of the
microscope we can use this robot to
acquire over two thousand leafy samples
per day still
provide a fairly high spatial resolution
of up to 1.2 microns
to help them to digest what is happening
for the polymorph infection
and to analyze those data they
propose a kind of a simple solution
instead of you know directly process the
entire image of the 8000 by 5000 pixels
they separate them into small patches
then you can feed the small patches to
the convolutional neural network and
classify that whether or not this patch
is infected or not
and then they somehow converted the
qualitative evaluation with quantitative
metrics right and then they can describe
the other module development over time
this is great because they use this
method to find you know maybe 10 to 20
more qtls that in capacity never have
the capacity to fund
and but it is perfect
especially from the data processing
perspective right
so when i revisit this image we
collected
i found okay that's fine by using a
binary classification to identify this
healthy one because they contain nothing
there
but for those infected patches you see
some of them only have a single height
here
but some of them be you know occupied
all by this hyphen
that means they have some local severity
difference
but by using these binary
classifications is you never pick up
those information and that's where the
accuracy is lost
and if we can pick up them probably we
can find better results for those
genetic analysis
but considering this problem you know we
probably have other solutions for
example we can use segmentation mode
right which
um you probably heard that ask a student
to label all this hyphy carefully and
then we can train a model that can also
find the high fee but that's very
expensive and costly right and also
sometimes it's just hard to find anyone
be able to draw the line accuracy to
identify positively
and i just you know as a ai
scientist i was just thinking this okay
instead of doing this quality of work
let's just take advantage of the current
label and see how we can push the
computational side to address this issue
right we found we already have the
expandable idea which means we do not
only make those neural networks work for
us we try to understand what's the
mechanism behind those neural networks
to make those decisions so specifically
for images that all the way project back
to the pixel which pixels supported the
classification of this image patch as an
infection
right so in this specific case if the
model being learned very well it will
find the pixels represent the height
then
we will have the information for us to
do better quantification so it's just a
perfect kind of a combination of two
purposes
so my lab developed this a little bit
different processing pipelines so the
key difference here is this part
so instead of just using the cnn
classifier we also run the cmsu map that
can reveal this important pixels that
support the classification prediction
and as i just mentioned if the model are
really learning the true knowledge you
should find those pixels on the hyphy
region right and then we can use that to
better quantify
the infection severity
so we just choose a very typical data
set previously collected for a biparent
or
mapping
family
and then first we want to make sure okay
all the classifiers really did their job
and yes they all achieved like over 95
accuracy which is pretty good for this
uh case but i want to highlight
simply some model here vgg16 actually
works the best puzzle performance is
marginal
but that's another indication that
sometimes to not blindly use the complex
neural network models
they sometimes never work out for your
simple questions
so after we got the most successful
model with the 16 we just learned the
synthesis map method and we got exactly
what we expect to see
okay so for this image patch as here and
i asked our expert to label the ground
truth you can see that's the use of pen
tool really carefully align the hyphal
and then for this classification-based
method you will consider the whole patch
being infected which means all the
pixels will be in faction pixels however
by using the synthesis maps either
gradient or graph count you can really
align well with the high feed part right
even for this very complex you know
pattern we can do a pretty good job and
that's where we bring the accuracy back
at the patch level and then when we
assemble all the patch together as a
leaf sample we see exactly trend as you
can see from the bottom to the to the
top
that's you know based on the human uh
counting you have different severity
however when you use the patch base
because any single small hybrid will
trigger that catch being classified as
infection
then you start to quickly just saturate
for your infection severity counts
although you see quite a different
number here for human evaluation but
they all look very similar for the patch
results
however if you compare with the
seniors-based method they roughly keep
the trend we are human-funded
that's the benefit of a branding that
accurately lost
so we did more uh quantitative
evaluation and fun you know by just
using this zenith map method without any
further annotation okay without any
further annotation we improve the
overall quantification accuracy by five
to six percent as compared with the
catchphrase method and also we just lost
about one second difference in the
processing time and if we push hard for
the you know catchphrase and method to
achieve similar spatial resolution in
the analysis then that's about 8500
times more faster
than that way so that really shows the
efficiency and efficacy of this pipeline
and then all the important thing is
regarding the genetic analysis right uh
and we apply the you know retrieve the
trees uh and back to use for uh qtl
analysis and we found for this patch
please either reported through our
previous application or the new analysis
it's a very random keycap right
sometimes you pick up a one cross
chromosome sometimes you do not it's not
very reliable
but by using the census map base of
trees you can always reliably pick up
both although sometimes it's marginal
but you are able to pick that means we
at least improve the lower boundary of
the qtl analysis and making sure we can
select more information through our
experiment
sadly
so in addition to that we will also find
some new you know uh phenomena that we
never been able to do in the past
because in the past we either focusing
on the number of hyphy or you know
whether or not the entire patch being
you know infected but here by using the
ceiling's base method we found these two
kind of infection patterns one is that
you have so many areas being infected
but each of them probably just have a
very you know short
uh spoiler relation or either a high
phone right but the other one you know
most of the area actually being occupied
by the extended high
rather than a lot of spirituality so
that may help us to think about back to
the field of management right if we use
different practices probably we can deal
with you know different genotypes more
effectively
um that just open new insight again to
link from breeding to management and
measurement back to breeding
so
to further you know
promote the use of the system we
developed this fine tuning the version
now is called blackbird you just need to
prepare the leaf disk and then
see the sample tree there it can
automatically acquire the data for you
without any staining process and we also
developed this
cloud-based analysis platform called
candle dragon once you collect all the
data you can just upload to the cloud
and select our pre-trained model or work
with us to develop your own model you
can quickly analyze all the data to
generate numbers that are meaningful for
your own experiments
and with that you know we also test the
different crops with different you know
uh pathogen and even beyond the plant
regime we test for the fish embryo try
to you know work on some fish breeding
projects and also recently we just
received a fund from usdars about ai
innovation to further you know promote
these tools within ars field labs that
can you know help to address different
biological questions you know across the
entire country
so with that i would like to thank all
my lab members my great collaborators
who put you know
great efforts on this project especially
for those who collect the data in the
field in the lab and annotate those
images
and also i would like to acknowledge all
our funding agencies to provide
financial support to the research we
conduct
with that i'd like to thank for your
attention and i'd be happy to take any
questions
questions
yep all right so i love your
presentation and i have two questions
so the first is for the map that you
showed with the hemp reading and i think
you're looking at the morphological
traits of the hem
what um
how did you collect that data was that
be a satellite or via a camera
yeah so for for that we develop our own
drone system with multi-model sensors
um so
back to that project
oh okay so the question was about the
map for the hemp breeding project
and how what's the system we use for
collected data so we developed our own
system
with multi-model sensors and back to
that time we have the high-resolution
rgb camera
as well as a 10-band multi-spectral
camera so that that will allow us to not
only retrieve the you know commonly used
ndvi but many other indices that may
provide a better correlation between
bell mass steel right
okay
that's good to know and then the second
question is about the strobe
uh and the
rape diseases
i noticed that you know as you mentioned
the humans seem to rate the speech
ratings higher but the strobe
what is its capability at sensing the
disease deeper into the canopy and
especially as airflow is reduced closer
to the stem of the plant is there any
way to account for that
possible
loss of
capability
yeah so the question was you know how we
compensate of those
in canopy
infection area right
that's a very good question so that's
actually the current limitation for all
this optical sensing method
we get the data for what we can see
right so we only see the other canopy
so that's the reason we only quantify
the disease infection for the auto
canopy
but there are
efforts ongoing research that we can
develop for example robotic arm that can
extend into the canopy and try to see
what's happening right
but there is always a debate
for research i mean that's fine because
we want to get the best understanding
of what's happening behind the plant
but for production there is a you know
critical needs that you need to draw
everything your very highest throughput
make sure you can have timely decision
making process
otherwise you can get 100 accurate of
all this infection but after you know
the amounts
there's no meaning for us to do that so
it's a it's a kind of a trade-off rather
than a simple decision whether or not we
want to look into but i think you know
with the research capability we probably
can build some you know model
try to see
if we get some you know good estimation
from the research product right between
the inner and other account of the
disease infection and we may eventually
build a model a company with other like
environmental factors as you mentioned
maybe wind speed or temperature humidity
that may help us to build eventually
build a usable model for production
system with
better thank you
thank you
any other questions
we have
one question
from
kathleen
automatically has a sample
okay yeah that's another great question
so currently at the development stage
uh we just predefined the weak points
the robot needs to stop by and then
extend the robotic arm collect the soil
sample and then bring back either to the
lab or just use some onboard quick
analysis device that can get the soil
you know property
but we are working in progress to make
the disease detection model to real-time
detection so with that capability i
would see in the future as long as we
find a severe infection or any other
like a predefined level of infection we
will let the trigger the robot stop and
collect the sample further now
we have something in that concrete
thank you very much
okay yeah thanks for the question
any other questions
oh
i need to use this okay
any other questions from zone
participants
so far i didn't see any
maybe they are just typing
the wait for
um
yeah uh yes some faculty colleagues said
excellent work
i wonder if you've done any computer
vision
uh
is this an active direction you might
have
my answer is yes
the the reason i did not present any
yield explanation for briefs is because
i have police collaborating together
kirsten peterson who is an assistant
professor gcp you've already worked on
that you know for a couple of years so i
would rather to bring your existing
technology integrated on the robot and
all of us right as i mentioned the
one-handed framework is to enhance and
foster the interdisciplinary
collaboration rather than you know
making the complete internal
communication
so with that we can quickly
is to understand what's the optimal you
know uh problem or yield in other words
all right virtually together we can
really do profit level of management
ensure the maximum
profitability for the growth and of
course that will ensure the maximum you
know kind of yield that's how we define
that but anyhow
[Music]
okay
thank you very much any other questions
okay no and i didn't see more questions
uh from the uh zoom but i guess they are
all impressed with your work
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu